انتشر منذ ايام مقطع فيديو لفتاه مصريه
تدعى ورود محمد وهي طالبه في كليه الطب
الفيديو كان اثار جدلا وحاله من الغضب في
الشارع المصري الجديد اليوم هو بيان رسمي
من وزارات السياحه والاثار دعونا بدايه
نشاهد الفيديو
[ضحك]
زي اي مكان ثاني يبقى ده كده مكان زباله
ولما حاولنا نتفاهم معاهم او نتكلم راحوا
قالوا الولد من الولد اللي معانا اللي هم
هيكتبوا لنا الامن واللي احنا بنعمله ده
حاجه مش كويسه وهيجيب لنا خالص من ايه بقى
ده اسمه ايه في تفاصيل الحديثه عهود ذهبت
هي وعدد من صديقاتها الى احد المطاعم في
مصر للاحتفال بعيد ميلادها لكنها تفاجات
بان العاملين في المكان لم يسمحوا لهن
بالدخول السبب هو تواجد صديقه محجبه بينهن
المطعم لم يخبرها مسبقا بانه يمنع دخول
المحجبات الى المكان او ان هناك قواعد
محدده للباس وبعد محاولات عديده هدد
العاملون في المطعم عهود وصديقاتها
باستخدام رجال الامن في حال عدم المغادره
وبمجرد ما تم نشر هذا الفيديو حتى اشتعلت
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي بالانتقادات
والجدل حول هذه الحادثه واغلبها درجه تحت
مسمى العنصريه وانه لا يجب ان يكون الحجاب
اصلا ضمن قواعد اللباس في المنشات وطلبوا
الجهات المعنيه باتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
من بعد كل هذا الجدل والمطالبات بالتدخل
الرسمي اصدرت وزاره السياحه والاثار بيان
قالت فيه انه تم تشكيل لجنه لتحقيق في
الحادثه وعند زياره المطعم شوهد عدد من
العاملات المحجبات داخله بالاضافه الى
تواجد فتيات محجبات داخل المطعم تم
التاكيد من قبل اداره المنشاه السياحيه
بانها تستقبل زوارها من دون اي قيود او
حتى استثناءات هذا البيان تناقض بشكل كامل
مع ما تم نشره من قبل عهود وصديقاتها
وللان لم يصدر اي بيان رسمي من قبل اداره
المطعم ينضم الينا لتعليق على الموضوع عبر
الهاتف هشام وهبي عضو غرفه المنشات
السياحيه هشام اهلا بك معنا في تفاعلكم
العربيه اولا ما الذي حصل تحديدا حول قضيه
المطعم التي اثارت جدلا كبيرا في مصر
بيؤكد عدم صحه ما تم تداوله عبر فيسبوك
بشان صيام احدى المنشات سحريه بمنع القول
المحجبات ضمن
وانه لا يحق لايهم انشاء فندقيه او سياحيه
منه دخول المحجبات لضوء قانون المنشات في
الفندقيه والسياحيه
حضرتك احنا اي بلاغ بيجي لازم بنتحقق منه
الاول تم تشكيل لجنه ونزلت لجنه تفتيش
بقياده الاستاذ علي حسن مدير الاداره
العامه للتفتيش على المطاعم السياحيه
بوزاره السياحه
تفتيش مفاجئ لقى انه في زبائن محجبات
موجودين داخل المطعم بالاضافه الى ثلاث
مواصفات محجبات شغالين داخل المحطه
بلاغ كايدي وهو مش بلاغ هو ما فيش بلاغ هو
تداول على الصفحات الفيسبوك
ناس عايزه تطلع ترند فبتعمل اي مشكله اي
حاجه انها
تحقيق الواقع
بدنا نتاكد منك من الناحيه القانونيه ليس
هناك اي قيود او تقييد لاي لبس معين داخل
منشات سياحيه قانون
رقم بيمنع اي مكان عام منشاه سياحيه او
فندقيه من التمييز ما بين الزباله ممنوع
يقول لسجون مفيش دخول ده اصل قانون
طيب البنات استاذ هشام قاموا بتصوير
الفيديو كما شاهدنا داخل المطعم واداره
المطعم ردت بان الخطا كان من موظف الذي
الذي قام بالحجز ولم يبلغن بانه المحجبات
ممنوعات من الدخول الى المطعم كيف ترون
ذلك
سعر
بقدر اعمل بلبله باي طريقه علشان اطلع
ترند واعمل مشكله للمطعم
لانه البنت نفسها ما تقدمتش حتى لبلاغ
رسمي للوزاره
يعني لو كان في مشكله كانت بلاش انما هو
مجرد خبر نشرته على صحتها على الفيسبوك
والناس تداولوه
ما فيش بلاغ رسمي ومع ذلك اتخذ الموضوع
على محمل الجد ونزلت لجنه عينه المكان
ودخلت المكان وشافت لقوا الكلام ده مش
صحيح طيب لماذا لم يكن هناك بلاغ او او رد
رسمي من قبل اداره المطعم بعد كل هذا
الجدل شاهدنا بيان من وزاره السياحه
والاثار لكن من اداره المطعم لم يكن هناك
اي تعليق سيد هشام
وزاره السياحه هي المصدره التلخيص وهي
المشرفه
طيب في تفاعلكم لابد ان اسمع منك سيد هشام
يعني جميع المنشات التابعه لوزاره السياحه
والاثار ليست لديها اي قيود او استثناءات
دخول اي زبون مهما كان شكله مهما كان لونه
مهما كان جنسيه شكرا جزيلا لك عبر الهاتف
حدثنا
هشامات السياحيه
[موسيقى]